hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my spider-man video we're gonna start
with Civil War and then go through all
the stuff we know about his new solo
trilogy including the villains that I
think they'll be using is far as we know
spider-man isn't going to show up right
away in Captain America's Civil War but
he will be team Iron Man he has stark
tech it seems like his eyes are actually
cameras that open and closed I don't
know how he controls us I'm guessing it
just suit tech his mechanical
web-shooters are also probably stark
tech who knows what else is going on
with it they might talk a little bit
more about the suit tech as we get
closer to the movie but most of the time
is going to be spent promoting Black
Panther Captain America and Iron Man's
characters so it's implied that sometime
during the movie he'll have this crisis
of conscience switch teams and kind of
go off on his own before he goes into
the solo film but that doesn't mean that
he is leaving the Avengers although
technically I don't know if you could
call him an adventure in this movie he's
really more of like a junior Avenger
candidate and training like once the
training wheels are off Iron Man will
give him the official a badge but I
wouldn't be surprised if somewhere in
his bedroom he has Avengers fanfare like
he has posters action figures anything
related to the Avengers Peter Parker's a
scientist so he's probably something of
an Iron Man fanboy before whatever big
fallout happens in Civil War but here's
the thing too part of the arrangement
for spider-man appearing in the Marvel
films is that Marvel characters appear
in the spider-man films just to help
give him that little bump so supposedly
the idea is that Captain America and
Iron Man will also have minor cameos in
that first Spider Man solo film they
don't have a title for it but because
Peter Parker is supposed to be 15 when
Captain America Civil War picks up he'll
either be finishing his freshman year in
high school or starting his sophomore
year the idea with the spider-man films
is that he starts out in high school and
each year is another year of high school
so by the last film he'll be a senior in
high school that's why they cast an
actor that was so young so that he
wouldn't wind up being a 35 year old
high school senior I'm sure you've all
seen one of those at your school the
movie itself is scheduled to come out
July 7th 2017 so you're talking like
around fourth of July weekend next year
the only other characters we know are
confirm right now our Aunt May who's
being played by Marissa Tomei in zendaya
who's listed as a character named
Michelle now Gwen Stacy's middle name is
Maxine
so they might be
changing her character a little bit you
could be like the african-american iris
West who knows the name Michelle is
probably just a placeholder because they
don't want to give it away but as you
know because he's already spider-man
he's already taken the mantle they're
not doing the Uncle Ben origin story
they'll probably reference it but
they're not gonna do a retelling of that
part of the origin story he's already
gonna be web slinging so most of the
action will be on whatever the big plan
the villain has in the movie which they
haven't confirmed yet they haven't said
which villain they're using but because
they're completely rebooting the
universe they're probably gonna stick
with a really safe bet which really
narrows the list down
spider-man's one of those characters
that's been really popular for a long
long time so just like Batman he has a
giant gallery of villains really big
well-developed villains so it's an
embarrassment of riches and Sony has
access to pretty much all of them and
because of their sharing arrangement
with Marvel who knows they might be able
to share a villain in the future too so
right off the bat number 10 would be
kingpin but because he's part of the
Netflix universe they're probably not
going to use him just because they want
someone even bigger more cinematic
number 9 jackals another really big
villain if you didn't read the
spider-verse stuff for Spider Island he
basically he was involved in a big Clone
Saga created a whole bunch of clones
made a bunch of spider beings he was
crazy so I'm not really expecting him to
be the villain either but he's one of
the big ones number eight Hobgoblin
little more likely good safe bet for
they probably want to do Green Goblin
before they did Hobgoblin so number
seven moving down the list chameleon
one of the earliest villains that
Spiderman fought he debuted during
amazing spider-man number one number six
Mysterio there are several versions of
the character I would prefer they just
stick with the original and do Quentin
Beck if they're going for a classic
characterization of the spider-man
character why not do the same thing for
the villain number five Sandman
just forget about all that business with
him being involved with Uncle Ben's
death during spider-man three number
four Doctor Octopus always a solid bet
no matter when you're rebooting the
comic they made him sit out Andrew
Garfield but we got to see the arms so
we knew he was coming eventually so now
they might as well do him number three
venom amazing spider-man villain but
here's the problem they're doing a venom
movie and it's not supposed to be Canon
with the new spider-man trilogy I know
that
sounds weird I think they just want
venom to be his own thing off in this
weird little universe they don't want to
bog down the new spider-man cannon with
anything that's going on so if venom is
really successful they'll probably
change their minds about that but for
now just assume the venom isn't gonna be
anywhere in this new spider-man trilogy
so number two Kraven the hunter kind of
a weird choice but the best Kraven story
of all time is Cravens last hunt is
actually from the 80s if they did that
storyline for the movie it'd be awesome
really though I think the striking
Cravens favor is that he's a big
cinematic villain that you can do that
they have not also done in recent memory
like they just did Green Goblin who's my
number one pick by the way Green Goblin
number one pick very safe bet but I feel
like Kraven is actually the more likely
pick that they'll go with for this first
spider-man film now for the second and
third spider-man films all bets are off
they're totally gonna have to bring back
someone that they've already done in the
sinister six we'll probably have a loose
role but as far as I know the sinister
six movie that they had on the books
earlier they were gonna do a spin-off
movie just for them is not happening
anymore
they might reboot their plans for that
but Kraven like I said likely candidate
for that first spider-man movie was one
of the original members of the sinister
six so they could still totally choose
to do it later I think they just want to
make sure that first spider-man film is
as strong as it could possibly be so
that everyone is totally down with more
spider-verse stuff but here's my
question for you guys let me know in the
comments who do you think that Cindy is
playing is she playing a version of gwen
stacy is she playing some other
character whoever she is she probably is
someone from the comics and if they are
doing craven craven does have a daughter
but her name isn't Michelle the
interesting thing is that Marc
Guggenheim showrunner from arrow
actually co-created Cravens daughter so
more Marvel DC crossover there's a lot
of people that work in television that
also write comics and just because you
work on a DC TV show doesn't mean that
you can't also write Marvel comics
there's a lot of weird coincidences like
that in the TV and movie universes where
you have writers for TV shows and movies
at one studio writing comics for another
his wife is actually the showrunner for
agent Carter so you have like two
different TV shows on different networks
for different comic book companies in
the same house it's so funny but here's
what's gonna happen next you might have
seen they just posted the x-men
apocalypse trailer
I'm totally gonna do a breakdown for
that Miami Vice
is going to kick some ass is gonna be a
lot of fun he's actually he's losing his
hair in the movie so this is nice Bryan
Singer continuity be sure to subscribe
to get that video all posted in the next
couple of hours and then there is
daredevil dropping at midnight so my
first video for that won't post til
tomorrow while you guys wait for that
next video to post you can click here
for my Black Panthers Civil War video
and you can click here for my big
trailer break down to the whole thing
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you